okay we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
a very good question here from someone
thinking ahead
about voting in november take a listen
hey david uh joe from california yeah um
hey i've been seeing online uh people
are suggesting
uh that they take their mail and ballot
their absentee ballot
to the polling place and dropping it off
right therefore not having to
uh put it on the post office to have to
mail it and send it in yep what do you
think good idea i think so
like to know your thoughts yeah so so
listen um the answer is
it's probably a good idea to go and drop
off your ballot if you're able to but
what you have to understand is the post
office is a public service
and there's a lot of people in this
country who don't have vehicles
and can't easily get to uh city hall
or wherever you can drop off your ballot
there are people who
live in really rural areas so even if
they have a car they'd have to take half
a day off from work to go and drop off
their ballot etc etc so
it really shouldn't depend on people
going and dropping off their ballot at
city hall in person
i plan to do it because boston is small
and i can do it right i'll just find
uh 20 minutes and i'll go over and and i
will drop it off
depending on where you live you may be
better off just
mailing the ballot early so yes it is a
good idea to go and drop off the ballot
in person
depending on your circumstances where
you have to drop it off
how much you trust the the male system
where you are and how early you're able
to send your ballot but certainly
something people should consider
on today's bonus show we will talk about
north korean literature leader kim
jong-un
reportedly condemning pet ownership as
decadence
and ordering dogs to be confiscated
we're going to talk about the texas
governor proposing freezing property tax
revenue
if a city defunds police and we will
talk about
businesses that are saying you know even
if trump does this payroll tax thing
we're just not going to do it we're not
going to participate so a lot of
important meaty stories on today's bonus
show
and remember that august 23rd that's
coming up august 23rd is the 15th
anniversary of the david pakman show
we will be having a single day
membership special
which you can be notified about by
signing up for our newsletter
at davidpakman.com i'll see you on the
bonus show